salut salut je pense que je suis assis ici je suis désolé
non je ne te connais pas d'ailleurs
pas que je sache que tu m'as l'air vraiment familier
mais oui salut nous faisons deux arrêts 62
McLaughlin Crescent vraiment et ouais pourquoi
tu vas où  vivre assez près en fait
oh je marcherai de chez toi
je suis marié oh c'est dommage
tu m'as manqué excuse mauvais tu es là ouais
tu es une bonne nouvelle nous savons que salut
Daniel c'est Louie c'est notre quartier
bienvenue un quartier devrait  nous commençons à
marcher hey hop je vais te faire un tour
Oh non j'ai toujours voulu en monter un le
voir chez mon mari semble t'aimer beaucoup
il le fait et je l'aime alors ce que tu es venu
ici pour me dire c'est solitaire  là-haut
devrions-nous avoir un chien chien est comme une
entrée pour un enfant non j'allais aimer une
entrée pour une vache ou un plus gros animal
envie d'être dans le monde avec
toi nous passons la journée ensemble
s'il vous plaît ouais je veux savoir quoi  elle a fait
Wow place maintenant une salle de gym aujourd'hui a
glissé sur peu de vie a un écart dedans ça le fait
juste entre les haut-parleurs d  ne deviens pas
fou en essayant de le remplir des jours pour un instant de
quoi as-tu peur
j'ai peur de me demander si ça me manque à
bientôt je te suppose